في على مفارقه في جهود الصين لتصبح اكثر
اعتمادا على نفسها ادخلت شركه خطوط شرق
الصين الجويه طائره سي
919 الى سوق الطيران المدني واكملت
الطائره امس اول رحلاتها التجاريه هذه
الطائره بدات تطويرها قبل 15 15 عاما
لتنافس طائرات ايرباص اي 320
وبوينج 737 ماكس ذات الممر الواحد وفقه
وسائل اعلام محليه يتوقع ان يصل الانتاج
السنوي منها الى 150 طائره طائره سي 919
في غضون خمس سنوات فقط
30% تقريبا او اكثر من اللي هو سوق
السيارات الصينيه مبيعا بس
داخلين نطقوا السيارات هو الطيارات هلا
اللافت في الموضوع بانه كل القطع غربيه
يتم تجميعها للسفينه
واللي هو شيء مستغرب كون انه يعني مصلحه
مصنع العالم هو الصين لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات